wait welcome to this video playing mr.
Boris here from the UK who is that Boris
Johnson probably not him if you get this
pretty often casual this is such a
natural looking move wow he's really
relaxed ye about all this this is
getting serious very quickly mr. Boris
let's see
gif form it's not exactly strengthening
the King position Knight f6 nigeria
forum and mate that's the IDM this line
is an absolute weapon name white
stumbles into that this is very
difficult to defend it in any time
control and in blitz defending against
us each file stuff is is just absolute
error
[Music]
so let's think about this for a moment
here what what is a possible way at
least to try to defend maybe 95 here
counter-attacking which i think i would
think about 96 there or Bishop g4 just
give the rook well giving the ruckus
probably not giving the rook um can I
def six and nine to four looks
absolutely absolutely devastating I can
also just flaking the eight I mean just
cover everything what happens if I play
this and Bishop I can actually do that
that's a good idea let's play this this
is a temple so 97 he cannot play he has
to do this first and then i can so long
that make sense yeah I get the
development going in here so does he
threaten to move the king he actually
does
that's five six
yeah can you wonder probably try to run
away what am i doing then d 5 maybe a d5
we're just taking I can also play no I
cannot I was thinking Bishop g4 it I
cannot ok so open up everything it looks
logically I open up the D file he takes
I take it's still a pin on the second I
mean actually this key days look aged
one they look aged one nothing I really
had on the radar he admittedly I did I
relax again yeah too much after this
fantastic position my usual problem
that's crazy Brooke eh bannen god dammit
I have to do this nonsense oh my god
that's really totally bad so can I do
this I had an idea here giving giving
giving the Queen it's a bit funky but i
think it's interesting you can of course
just take one g two way I am check and
escape this I cannot believe that is not
mated oh I completely screwed it up just
friggin awful
check we have a equal ending great
amazing really amazing check
check I'm really really amazed that i
didn't manage to to kill the song it is
such such an absolutely unplayable
position void and i didn't manage now i
put myself or desserts from the other or
what probably check check
time morning tricky old soon but i can
if i do this check there's no made
strangely enough check check check
person I'd my god I did not win this out
of the opening I'm completely completely
stunned but this must be okay right and
what did I do wrong them let I don't get
it what was wrong Knight f6 the engine
one second I can switch it on any wants
to take here and then go back to age
seven yeah it's good but instead of back
move aside you can you can do that
already right okay now i have this thing
which is actually very good now we have
to take take and then d 5 carat I'm not
meeting him I'm absolutely not meeting
in that cannot be true really I must
have some kind of meeting attack here to
have something better here I mean okay
that was winning the other stuff but I
cannot believe he's not mated it seems
to be the case stuff like bishop
g4 is not stronger am king of two that's
the defense on this one I just looking
after we are check yeah that doesn't
work I kind of suspected that much King
F to check this one that also doesn't
look like before us check me check yeah
then then I am landed on to all this now
I realize that I cannot do this because
of who page one that can host a bit of a
later inside yeah this I felt should be
very interesting and he has to probably
give away the something like that he's
not surviving check and then we we got
this this equal ending here the ND why I
could have actually taken yet who gave
one now that's the benefit that's better
for you I intend to relax a I have such
an overwhelming British tanks tend to
relax here this is equal I shouldn't be
won by black boots okay he had to spend
lots of time not to get checkmated Amir
limb okay thanks for watching